it's good to have you company welcome to
the NewsHour Moscow has accused the U.S
government of fighting an indirect war
against Russia using Ukrainian soldiers
instead of its own the comment follows a
visit to Washington DC by a Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski his first
overseas trip since Russian troops
invaded nearly a year ago in an address
to Congress lensky said the supply of
military aid for Kiev was an investment
in Global Security and democracy the
eastern city of bahut is now the
epicenter of the war Ukrainian forces
have held their ground in a territory
Russia could use to advance on other
cities if it takes control
well Salama is standing by for us in
Moscow but first let's hear what Charles
Stratford has to say from the capital
Kiev
UT is undeniably one of the hottest
places along that 1300 kilometer front
line it's a city that has been fought
for with increasing intensity I suppose
over the last sort of five months of
this 10-month war
um and it's fair to say that um suddenly
in the last month or so the Russians
have made very little uh Advance we know
that the fighting is a special tense in
the east of the city this is a place
that has now been called a meat grinder
and that's with reference to that world
war one battle of Verdan where tens of
thousands of soldiers were killed we
understand that thousands of ukrainians
and Russian soldiers have been killed in
the battle for Bak moot many civilians
as well we also know that there are
still surprisingly quite a few civilians
in that town refusing to leave
um largely as is usually the case
because they have no else to go and
they're worried about their properties
Mahmoud is strategically important
because it is potentially a gateway to
other large cities in the donets region
the cities of crematost and slavians but
it's it's fair to say that the situation
has come to a very brutal War of
Attrition and a stalemate
well that's because I have to Moscow now
and speak with Al jazeera's
correspondent Salam before we talk about
reaction to zelenski's visit to the U.S
let's just talk about the iaea chief
he's been in Russia again trying to
avoid any potential sort of nuclear
incident I mean what's come out of that
meeting and that visit
so hello Grossi has arrived this morning
to Moscow and he had a very long meeting
if we may say so with the head of the
Russian Atomic agency in the meeting
there were representative also of the
ministry of the defense the Russian
Ministry of Defense the Russian Ministry
of Foreign Affairs and also a
representative from the national Gods
the Russian national guards who are the
main troops that are now present in
zapprochia a nuclear plant after the
meeting nothing official was announced
just Raphael Grossi tweeted saying that
it's very important to establish a
security Zone along the porosia nuclear
plant in order to avoid a nuclear
incident also the head of the Russian
nuclear agency Alexei legaczov has said
that a reproachment has been observed
during the meeting between the two
parties on a possible draft of
establishing a security Zone in the
saying that now more consultations will
go on with the iaea in order to uh to uh
draft a mutually accepted proposal on
that zone just to remind the usual and
everyone else that Russia continuously
is saying that it has no problem
establishing this Zone along the porogia
with one very important condition which
is that the soldiers the Russian
soldiers especially from the National
Guard shall remain in the puroshia
zaporosia is one of four Ukrainian
regions that Moscow has annexed last
October after a very disputable uh
referendum indeed of course many moving
parts to the story today for Ukraine
let's talk about reaction from Russia in
terms of that very warm uh welcome that
zielinski got in Washington DC and a
promise of more arms and more funding
that's going to anger Moscow
as indeed Sohail we've heard today from
the spokesman of the KREM Kremlin and Mr
Dmitry peskov he said that the visit in
itself shows that neither Kiev nor DC
are willing to sit and talk about the uh
conflict in in Ukraine also pescop said
that all the arms especially the Patriot
systems that the United States has
promised to provide Kiev with will be a
legitimate Target to the Russian army
also all the trainers the military
trainers all operators if they have been
sent and deployed on the in Ukraine The
Westerns and the Americans will also be
a legitimate Target to the Russian army
this is what peskov had said also he
added that these continuous shipments of
arms will only prolong the agony of the
Ukrainian people and it will not hinder
Moscow to achieve the goals of what
Moscow called the special operation in
Ukraine which is the war there Russell
for the update thanks very much our
correspondent there for us in Moscow